The anomalous religions that the SCP Foundation
has cataloged and studied over the years are
many in number and bottomless in depth, with
specialized para-theological researchers limiting
themselves to just one or maybe two faiths,
diving fully into a religion of their choice
and mastering its forbidden knowledge.
But the Foundation is careful to make sure
that those researching these faiths don’t
succumb to their beliefs, as many anomalous
religions are dangerous to the organization
in practice, involving tasks such as making
blood pacts with ancient gods, or modifying
one’s body to better suit a divine purpose.
There’s some seriously nasty stuff involved
in the immaterial world, almost to the point
where it makes you wonder why anyone would
be suckered into joining up with what appears
to be from the outside, just another cult
of crazies.
But let’s not generalize.
Religions, even those that are non-anomalous,
are all strange from the outside, even if
one may seem natural to you.
But one anomalous religion stands out from
all the rest as having more active followers,
more history, and more documented culture
than any other, and that is Sarkicism.
Hold on to your flesh, because today on SCP
Explained, we’re going to be answering the
question “What is Sarkicism?”, and hopefully
don’t get distracted and ritually sacrifice
you, the viewer, in the name of the Grand
Karcist Ion along the way.
Let’s get to it, meatbags.
Before we begin, it’s important to note
that Sarkicism is an incredibly dense and
deep religion, and that covering every last
detail of it in a short period of time would
be a herculean, nigh-impossible task for even
the most well-read Sarkic lore-masters.
So where would you even start?
What is Sarkicism?
To best understand that, we’re going to
bring you back all the way to the beginning
of human history, to the ancient world of
the Eurasian continent, where sprawling empires
ruled and war between them was an all-too-common
occurrence.
In what is now south-central Siberia, the
Daevite Empire ruled with an iron fist.
The Daeva were a warrior culture, with militarism,
conquest, gruesome human sacrifice, and thaumaturgic,
magic rituals being universally consistent
in their culture, according to the few historical
accounts available that make mention of the
empire.
The Daevites practiced anomalous magic, arcane
rituals, and sacrifices that bolstered their
power, longevity, and standing within their
society.
The empire was ruled by a theocratic aristocracy
called the daeva, those who were especially
attuned to the anomalous world, who practiced
cannibalism and thaumaturgy, and whose bodies
were so warped and modified by decades of
magic alteration that Foundation historians
would come to the conclusion that the Daeva
were so divergent from modern humans that
they could be considered a separate species
altogether.
But how the Daeva relate to Sarkicism remains
the question.
And the answer is found in the Empire’s
slave-owning culture.
The Daevites owned many, many slaves.
People they had bought or taken from their
lands as a sign of pure Daevite power in the
form of ownership over another human being.
Daevite city states had massive, sprawling
slave populations, and among those, was a
young boy by the name of Ion.
Ion’s appearance would be depicted over
the years by Sarkic art and culture as inconclusive
and varied, whether it was their gender, or
even the question of whether or not Ion resembled
a human, the cult of personality that would
crop up around Ion would be a testament to
Sarkicism’s eventual widespread culture,
but it was here, in ancient western Siberia,
where those seeds of Sarkicism originated.
According to the most prominent Sarkic texts,
Ion was a slave, like many others in the Daevite
empire.
Born into slavery by a Daevite mother and
a concubine father, the circumstances of Ion’s
birth indicate that he was destined to be
a slave from the onset.
But there was something remarkable about them.
Ion, in the eyes of his masters, was different
from other slaves.
He was intelligent, and so much so that the
decision was made for Ion to serve under a
Daevite priestess, where he could hone his
skills to serve the empire in ways unlike
the other slaves, who toiled away constructing
massive public works or died in foreign lands
on the field of battle.
Ion did not understand what differentiated
him from others, and why he deserved such
special treatment, but it was the realization
that the only thing separating him from his
masters was the possession of power that would
serve as the basis for Sarkicisms founding
doctrines.
Ion watched in horror as those they knew succumbed
to the backbreaking work that the empire forced
upon its slaves, and how prevalent death and
destruction were among its people.
Inside Ion grew a great rage for the Daevites,
who flaunted their power over others in the
form of slavery.
He wished to transcend the physical limitations
that kept him and his fellow slaves in bondage
and service to the Daevites.
Ion knew that their masters practiced thaumaturgy,
a form of magic that granted great power to
its users, and in a brutal world where power
is what defines who is master and who is slave,
the prospects of achieving it became more
important to Ion than anything else.
If he could harness such power for himself,
Ion could break free from the chains of slavery
that kept him subservient to those Daevite
masters.
He would achieve apotheosis, the belief that
an individual could ascend to godhood through
raw power and unbridled will.
Over time, Ion's hatred of the so-called “living
gods” of the Daeva grew so strong that he
actively began plotting their downfall.
Around 1800 BCE, Ion’s influence among the
lowest ranks of the empire was inescapable.
He was charismatic, he was a slave, he was
powerful, and he spoke of violence.
Of seizing Daevite magic for himself and using
it to elevate himself into power.
Ion’s tenets and beliefs appealed to the
slave population, who also grew hungry for
freedom.
Ion’s creed spread like wildfire, and would
form the basis for all Sarkic belief in the
centuries that came.
First, there was apotheosis, which Ion was
striving to achieve, and the path to doing
so was the will to power.
The next belief covered that concept in depth.
Ion believed that the will to power was the
primary driving force of man, as an individual
seeks to master all things within its domain,
they exert that power onto others, and others
have the ability to exert it back in opposition.
Desire is the measure of power, and those
with a stronger will always triumph over the
weak.
The next belief was the act of Theophagy,
a hypothetical tenant that Ion was toying
with after observing the Daevite religion
for years.
Theophagy referred to the act of sacrificial
consumption of a god, and upon eating them
achieving thaumaturgical, reality-bending,
and all-powerful abilities.
There were many gods in the universe, and
this Ion knew, but none of them were fit for
him to worship.
Instead, he would crave their power.
As a metaphorical example of theophagy, Ion
wanted nothing more than to consume the Daevite
empire whole, taking its power for his own.
Next, there was the idea of sacrifice.
Whether it was for the sacrifice of the self
for the benefit of many, or sacrifice of many
for the benefit of the individual, Ion believed,
much like his masters, that ritual sacrifice
was a powerful tool that could be used as
a means to achieve an end.
Those who commanded the sacrifice were showing
their power, bringing them that much closer
to apotheosis.
Those who were sacrificed were experiencing
strife, which would only make them stronger
than before.
Muscles suffer damage, but eventually heal.
The mind develops toleration against hardship,
such as slavery.
This cycle of destruction and regeneration
in strife was, according to Ion, one of the
greatest tutors in the natural world.
Ion’s final core belief would become the
most prominent, outward facing indicator of
Sarkicism, and that was the idea of “shepherding
the flesh”.
Ion believed that all living things descended
from a single progenitor, an all-powerful
god known as Yaldabaoth, who the Sarkics would
later regard as the principal power in the
universe.
Yaldabaoth’s relationship with Sarkicism
is tenuous at best, with modern Sarkic cults
either admiring or fearing the enemy.
One thing is certain though, Yaldabaoth remains
present in all Sarkic culture, even if the
religion doesn’t exactly worship the god
itself.
Yaldabaoth was a destroyer, who fed upon gods,
worlds, and stars, who incidentally created
the entire universe and life itself as a result
of its power-hungry actions.
The creation stories talk of Yaldabaoth as
a blind entity, driven solely by instinct,
fueled by the forces of primordial chaos.
As life was created as a result of Yaldabaoth’s
existence, it was ultimately unguided by intelligence,
and its spread throughout the universe was
similar to that of a germ than anything grand
or divine.
Ion, upon learning of these myths, came to
the conclusion that the multiverse itself
was only an altar that held life’s existence,
which was brought into reality for the ultimate
sacrifice at the hands of Yaldabaoth.
The entity would one day reclaim all of existence
for itself, harvesting what it created and
consuming it whole, as this was Yaldabaoth’s
nature and purpose as the ultimate being of
the cosmos.
Ion saw this shared ancestry among life as
the key to genetic modification.
As all life was derived from Yaldabaoth, it
held a similar genetic code, and it would
become the Sarkic right to guide and cultivate
organic matter, stealing the genes of other
lifeforms or creating entirely new ones.
Through this perversion of life, Ion felt
he could ascend from something ordinary to
a living god, fueled by the unending cycle
of sacrifice and creation.
With his radical, power-hungry beliefs rapidly
spreading throughout the Daevite empire, mostly
among its slaves, the leading Daeva became
fearful of Ion.
Attempts to assassinate him or usurp Ion’s
influence were met with failure, and only
fueled the mission of his followers, furthering
the belief that if they were to achieve godhood,
they had to overthrow the Daevites, who were
the most present, all-powerful beings in their
lives.
This all came to a head when Ion launched
his final act against the Daevite empire.
After years of sowing the seeds of disharmony
and hate among the slave population, Ion rallied
his followers and swept them up into a full-scale
rebellion.
In a short time, Ion overthrew the province
he grew up in, fueled by the rage of his followers,
who mercilessly razed the city and slaughtered
the Daevites like animals.
Those who were present could see the inspiration
Ion brought to his followers, how he commanded
them as if he were a living god.
How he used the reality-bending magic of the
Daeva and turned it against them, with his
followers utilizing anomalous warfare in a
horrific, gruesome way.
Flesh was turned into a weapon, living beings
were contorted and transformed into monstrosities
and abominations that fueled the Sarkic war
machine.
Daeva thaumaturgy simply could not compete
against the permeating, powerful, and unrestricted
abilities of Ion’s followers.
Before long, the city fell before the being
who had, in that moment of bloodlust and fury,
achieved apotheosis.
The being who was now known as the Grand Karcist
Ion.
The Grand Karcist and his followers rampaged
throughout the ancient world, felling cities
and entire empires to serve as stepping stones
in their path to godhood.
Their weapons and armor were unlike anything
else at the time, and their utilization of
powerful, flesh-bending magic made them unstoppable
on the field of battle.
The city of Adytum was established as the
Sarkic holy city, where Ion ruled as the Sorcerer-King
as a living deity.
Texts from this period suggest that Ion had
somehow usurped control of Yaldabaoth the
Devourer itself, wearing the flesh of the
Old God as a sort of armor, and crafting a
kingdom from its body.
While this depiction is most likely only a
metaphor for how much Ion resembled Yaldabaoth
in philosophy and pure power, the image of
a living god devouring and succeeding the
old one is a striking visual that surely empowered
many Sarkics at the time.
Another story from Sarkic mythology during
this period is “The Six Ordeals of Ion”,
a parable that told of six challenges that
were issued to Ion by the Archons, the servants
of Yaldabaoth, who challenged the newly crowned
king of Adytum.
By enduring their trials, Ion mastered the
rituals, practices, and beliefs ubiquitous
to Sarkicism and broke free from the bondage
of mortal limitations.
But the authenticity of this myth is debated,
and the nature of the ordeals and Ion’s
further relationship with Yaldabaoth remains
unknown.
But why did the Grand Karcist Ion, with his
flowing red robes and wielding his all-powerful
staff, who twisted flesh and drew blood when
he so much as drew breath, fall into such
obscurity that his religion remains a mysterious
and obscure footnote in the Foundation’s
archives?
If the Sarkics were as powerful as these early
texts state, where are they today?
Why did the horrific city of Adytum, built
of living, organic material that stood monument
to Ion’s indomitable will, fall?
In Sarkicism’s golden age, from 1600 and
1200 BCE, the religion’s permeation was
inescapable.
Like the diseases they wielded in their wars,
Sarkicism spread like a contagion across the
world.
Everywhere they went, they assimilated tribes
and villages into their ranks, fighting under
the banner of Adytum and the Sarkic faith.
This expanded empire would be referred to
as Kalmaktama, or the “Deathless”.
Many tried to defeat these brutal invaders,
including the king of the Hittite empire himself,
but all fell before them.
As the Kalmaktama Empire attempted to establish
a foothold in the Mediterranean, invading
and colonizing the islands of Cyprus, Crete,
and Gyaros, for the first time in Sarkic history,
the tides of war began to turn against the
religion.
A coalition of kingdoms was formed in response
to the Sarkic threat, created by the Egyptians,
Greeks, Minoans, Canaanites, Assyrians, and
most importantly, the Mekhanites, who were
the followers of the Church of the Broken
God.
The cult of Mekhane, the Broken God, had urged
these kingdoms to unite against the Sarkic
threat, and now united, outfitted their allies
with superior, Mekhanite technology that anomalously
enhanced the empires’ war capabilities,
putting them on-par with the Sarkic death-sorcerers.
And so, a great war was waged between the
Kalmaktama Empire and the Coalition of Kingdoms.
The details of such are largely lost to time,
but the war itself was fought with the full
power of the Sarkics and the Mekhanites clashing
with one another, and its consequences left
an imprint on the earth itself.
A death toll that estimates place at 20 to
30 million, mass graves, anomalous weapons,
and even the deployment of giant, mechanical
beings created by the Mekhanites known as
“Colossi” that rampaged through Sarkic
settlements and cities.
Though the battle was costly on both sides,
the Kalmaktama Empire fell to the Coalition,
and the once impenetrable city of Adytum was
destroyed, forever.
Sarkicism would fall into obscurity, and the
empire would be forgotten, possibly because
it was much easier than remembering the horrors
Ion subjected the world to.
The Grand Karcist himself disappeared, his
whereabouts unknown shortly after the fall
of Adytum.
Some said he had ascended into godhood, leaving
the world behind.
Others said he was slain in battle, nothing
more than a man who believed he would never
die.
The Sarkic religion was effectively extinguished
from the world, never to be seen again.
Or so, that’s what the coalition was led
to believe.
Though the empire and Adytum fell, and Ion
disappeared, an idea as tantalizing and powerful
as Sarkicism is difficult to snuff out entirely.
In reality, Sarkicism would continue in secret,
in both its homeland in the Urals and among
the offshoot tribes that had fought under
Adytum’s banner.
These sects of Sarkicism would practice their
beliefs in their war-ravaged homeland, which
suffered a great collapse, resulting in the
fall of kingdoms, a crisis of refugees, and
a decline of art, literature, science, and
technology.
Lingering disease and famine from Sarkic biological
weapons spread even to the kingdoms of the
coalition, resulting in an event historians
refer to as the Late Bronze Age Collapse.
The empire that was once Deathless had now
fallen, but its followers remained, practicing
their power-craving rituals in secret and
without centralization.
This led to a Sarkic diaspora, where various
sects and Sarkic cults, each with culturally
distinct beliefs, would crop up throughout
the Eurasian continent.
While the Foundation is unsure of the specifics
of these cults’ activities and beliefs,
elements of Sarkicism would soon begin to
permeate the upper echelon of society.
Infiltrating Carpathian cults or sought out
by nobles themselves, who ignored the rumors
of devil worship and witchcraft to seek out
Sarkic power for their courts.
The tempting power that Sarkicism granted
made it a popular choice to be practiced in
secret by upper-ranking royals and even entire
noble families.
From their position of power, where they had
access to knowledge, influence, and a fresh
supply of sacrifices, Sarkicism endured.
Over time, this would result in the formation
of Sarkic “Great Houses”, where families
practiced their own interpretation of Sarkicism,
the religion that was now mutated into hundreds
upon hundreds of variations and subcultures.
These great houses would focus on individualism,
and applying their powers to fulfill their
self-serving needs.
Sarkicism, now decentralized completely, would
spread throughout Europe via marriage, as
a high society of cults and magicians whose
true motives for ruling their kingdoms and
provinces were kept hidden behind their meaty,
flesh-curtain of absolute secrecy.
Today, the Sarkic cults persist, and their
anomalies are frequently uncovered by the
Foundation.
Understanding them and their religion, however,
is another ordeal entirely, and the majority
of Sarkic history, culture, and practices
are unknown to the organization.
But they’re still out there.
In the highest ranks of urban society, in
the most remote villages of the world.
There will always be those who crave to wield
flesh.
The followers of Ion who hope to achieve Apotheosis,
however they may believe they can do so.
Though the details remain unclear, there is
one thing the Foundation has realized over
its years of studying the religion: Sarkicism
has, and always will, remain.
Now go check out “SCP-3989 - The Bone Orchard”
and “SCP-610 - The Flesh That Hates” for
more of those squishy Sarkicists!